foreign
as we know with the increasing demand in
the project requirements for different
companies we require new software along
with different operating systems for
applications which creates more data and
we need more processing power and more
memory but there's a way to overcome
such situations known as virtualization
hi guys and welcome to another exciting
video by simply learn but before we
begin if you like watching Tech videos
subscribe to our Channel and hit the
Bell icon to never miss an update so to
understand what exactly virtualization
is let's take a look at an example so
beat Jake he works as a software
developer in an IT firm and he often has
to work on different projects involving
multiple operating systems according to
the requirements of the project during
which you often come across cases where
the managing of data becomes problematic
due to the compatibility issues with the
different operating systems which makes
it hard for the completion of the the
project so what can Jake do to overcome
such a problem well to overcome such a
problem he decided to use the way of
virtualization
but what is virtualization and how does
it help us
well let's take a look
to begin with we'll take a look at what
exactly virtualization is and how it can
help us then we'll understand what
virtual machines are after that we learn
about the role and different types of
hypervisor that are involved during the
process of virtualization after that we
learn what different types of
virtualizations are available and how
differently they affect our systems and
lastly we will see what benefits
virtualization provides us with to begin
with we'll understand what
virtualization is
virtualization is nothing but utilizing
a software to create a virtual layer
over the hardware which allows the
system Hardware to be used more
efficiently and allows appropriate
return for a hardware cost the software
hypervisor also allows the elements of
the system like storage memory processor
and Etc to be distributed among multiple
separate and secure virtual computers
known as virtual machines to understand
the situation of virtualization much
better let's take a look at an example
this is a system installed with the
Windows operating system which is
officially known as the host OS where
the virtualization software known as the
hypervisor will run
and then using the hypervisor software
we can have multiple instances of
different OS including Unix Mac and
Linux which are known as virtual systems
or guest OS
the working of the virtualization is
only possible by using a software known
as a hypervisor and later in the video
we will also learn about the working and
different types of hypervisor involved
now that we have understood what
virtualization is let's take a look at
what a virtual machine is
so as the name suggests virtualization
is nothing but an emulation or a virtual
representation of a physical operating
system on a hardware device
the virtual machines are also known as
guest OS whereas a physical system that
they run on is also known as the host OS
now let's take a look at the software
that makes the virtualization possible
hypervisor is a software layer that
manages the virtual machines
it forms an interface between the
physical system and the virtual machine
which ensures the proper access of the
resources
it also manages the virtual machine so
that they don't interfere with each
other's resources
let's take a look at what different
types of hypervisors are there
the first type of hypervisor is known as
the type 1 hypervisor or the bare metal
hypervisor this type of hypervisor
directly interacts with the hardware
system and user resources
the other type of hypervisor is known as
the type 2 hypervisor which runs as an
application on the host operating system
and the hypervisor also coordinates with
the virtual machine for resource
management
let's take a look at the type 1
hypervisor they run directly on top of
the host operating system and utilize
the hardware resources and that is why
they're also known as the bare metal
hypervisor they take up the place of the
host operating system and works as the
own operating system
and since this type of hypervisor Works
directly on the hardware system they are
highly efficient now that we understand
type 1 hypervisor let's take a look at
the type 2 hypervisor this type of
hypervisor doesn't directly work on the
operating system Hardware but instead it
works as an application in the host
operating system where they are suitable
for running individual systems users can
also have different multiple OS
installed in the physical system by
using this type of hypervisor
due to the application-based working of
the type 2 hypervisor they are also
known as virtual machine monitors or in
short vmms
now that we understand what different
types of hypervisors there are let's
take a look at what types of
virtualizations are present
the first type of virtualization is the
desktop virtualization then the network
virtualization storage virtualization
and lastly the application
virtualization let's take a look at them
one by one for desktop virtualization as
the name suggests in this type of
virtualization we can run multiple
operating systems on a single Hardware
system let's take a look at the
different types of desktop
virtualization the first one is virtual
desktop infrastructure or in short vdi
which runs numerous virtual machines on
a central server and then hosted to the
user according to the user's requirement
in this way the user can access any
operating system without having to
physically install the particular
operating system in its Hardware system
the second one is known as local desktop
virtualization as the name suggests it
uses a hypervisor software on a local
system which allows a user to run
multiple operating systems
simultaneously without having to affect
the host operating system
the next type of virtualization is
Network virtualization
in this type of virtualization the
software creates a virtual instance of
the network that can be used to manage
from a single console and it also forms
the abstraction of the hardware
components and functions including
switches routers and Etc which
simplifies the network management
different types of network
virtualization are software-defined
virtualization which virtualizes the
hardware that controls the network
traffic routing and the other one is
Network function virtualization
virtualize is the Hardware Appliances
that provide Network specific functions
easier to configure and manage for
example a firewall let's take a look at
the third type of virtualization known
as the storage virtualization this
virtualization enables all the storage
devices on the system to be accessed and
be managed as a single storage unit the
storage virtualization collects all the
storage into a single pool from which
they can allot another virtual machine
on the same network as required and this
makes it easier to assign storage for
multiple virtual machines with maximum
efficiency and the last virtualization
that we'll discuss is the application
virtualization in this type of
virtualization process the application
runs directly without the need of
installing it into the system as they
run on a virtual environment different
types of application virtualization app
the local application virtualization and
this type of application runs on the
host device but runs in a different
virtual environment but not in the
hardware
the second one is application
virtualization and in this the
application is on the server side and it
sends some of the components to the host
device according to the requirement and
last is the server-based application
virtualization this application runs
directly on the server side and sends
only the interface to the client system
now let's take a look at the benefits of
virtualization the first one is resource
efficiency
as the name suggests before
virtualization each application server
used its own Hardware resources which
were being underused but with having
multiple virtual machines maximum
utilization of the hardware capacity
occurs
then we have minimum downtime which
refers to the crashes of operating
systems and applications which can cause
a halt in the user productivity by using
virtualization the admin can run
multiple similar virtual machines
simultaneously and change over the
working instances in case of a crash
instead of having multiple dedicated
servers
and then we have time management
buying installing and configuring a new
system is not only costly but also a
waste of time
in such a case virtualization can solve
the problem provided that the existing
Hardware resources are sufficient for
running the virtualization software
otherwise it can be configured for the
same
now that we have reached the end of the
module in which we learn what is
virtualization what is the virtual
machine and how do hypervisor work
during the process of virtualization we
can use this process to make our work
easier if you have any doubts you can
ask them in the comments section and
thank you for watching
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learned YouTube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos turn it up and get certified
click here